Brian sound test.
What do you have for breakfast?
I had an Omelet and I'll know what
was in the outlet. Peppers, onions,
onions, onions, peppers,
tomatoes with no meat.
I love how you reordered those
ingredients. The mind of Brian at work.
Optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
living this year.
This episode is brought to you by
Athletic Greens. I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day, and you can get 50 oh my
God, 50% off. Yes, 50% off.
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash. Tim, check it out.
It's tasty but more important it will
help you not screw up when you're doing
your nutritional plannings.
So for me it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99
designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups
that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York
Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took
place with designers from around the
world. And here's how it works. Whether
you need a t shirt, a business card,
a website and APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing it in
the future. But in the meantime,
if you want to see some
of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get
a free $99 upgrade to 99 designs.com
forward slash. Tim, that's 99
designs.com forward slash. Tim, right?
Hello midnight mad hatter's.
This is Tim Ferriss.
It's very late and I am sing songs in my
intro to you in a sultry voice because
there are people sleeping in my house
and I don't want to wake them up,
but I had to record this intro because
I want to get this episode to a s a p.
It is a really fun one.
For those of you who are joining
the Tim show for the first time,
don't take my lack of
seriousness for lack of content.
We have a very important
mission here on the program,
which is to deconstruct
world class performers,
to interview people like billionaire
investors, just prodigies,
actors like Arnold Swartz and anger and
so on and so forth and everything in
between. We have athletes,
we have memory champions,
and there are commonalities across all
of these different disciplines and my job
is to tease out the beliefs,
the routines, the rituals,
the favorite books, all of the tidbits
that you can apply in your own life.
And this episode is no exception.
Had a blast with this.
My guest was a friend and very
impressive entrepreneur and investor,
Brian Johnson. That's Bryan with a
y. He is the founder of Ostp Fund,
which I'll explain in a
second and brain tree.
He sold the ladder to Ebay in
2013 four 800 million in cash.
Now that is more than enough to retire
and kickback and a hammock and lather
yourself with coconut butter
for the rest of your life,
but he is not one to rest on his laurels.
He took the Elon Musk approach and took
$100 million of his personal capital to
launch the OSTP fund that was in 2004.
And the entire fund is intended to
support crazy inventors and scientists who
aimed to benefit humanity by rewriting
the operating systems of life.
And in this interview,
it will explain what that means,
but it is going to stretch
you to think very, very big,
hopefully much bigger than you
thought possible for yourself.
So if his investments to give you an idea,
include endeavors to cure age related
diseases and radically extend human
lifespan to 100 plus human longevity inc.
And we talk about this in this episode,
making a biology,
a predictable programming language.
So how can you program Dna,
uh,
and biology to produce what you want?
Like Ginkgo bioworks and
synthetic genomics, uh,
replicate the human visual cortex using
artificial intelligence companies,
vicarious mine,
precious resources off of asteroids
with companies, planetary resources,
and many others.
So Brian is not only a
scrappy rags to riches story,
but he is someone who,
who succeeded and had a massive success
story in a technical field without
technical training and also just
a very deep, soulful good guy.
And all of those things combined
make for a fun conversation.
I hope you enjoy it as much as I did.
And without further ado,
please meet Brian Johnson.
Brian, welcome to the show.
Hi Tim. Thanks for having me.
And this is,
this is our take two.
We had a rough auditions start.
We were sitting in a park
and we had this guy fooling around in
the bushes who then asked us if we had a
spare backpack. I thought
that was an odd request. Yeah,
I think we are missing something.
He,
I don't think I was the real request
and we did not have a spare backpack.
Uh, but we, we were put sufficiently on
edge by this guy in meandering around us,
like doing concentric circles, like a
shark around somebody in a lifeboat.
Then I decided it was better to do it
inside. So we're at Casa Ferris and, uh,
I want to look at this and
kind of a medical context
because I've been hoping to
have you on the podcast for so long.
And we were talking just before starting
recording about what questions I might
ask and giving you sort of an overview.
And I had no idea that
you'd done any prep,
but I wanted you to tell me a little
bit about it because you asked,
how can we make this a
home run? And I said, well,
I think we will want to focus on stories.
And uh,
I will also typically judge it by how
many notes people take. And you're like,
well, that's really interesting.
You should say that.
So maybe you could talk about,
since we first discussed
doing the podcast together,
how you've been thinking about it.
Yes, I guess I, I love efficiency.
And so as I contemplate if I'm going to
spend 60 minutes of my time listening to
something, I want some value.
And so specifically I want
to have, you know, five,
six, seven takeaways. And
so I thought ahead of time,
what could I do in the shortest amount
of time that would create the most value
in someone's life. And, uh, so I think I,
this made me very excited because I
wanted to have you on, first of all,
but second of all,
you'd thought about it very methodically,
which shouldn't have surprised
me at all. Uh, we've,
we've taken a lot of hikes together
and had a lot of long talks,
very wide ranging, and I think we'll
get into a good amount of it. Uh,
let's start kind of at the
beginning and, uh, we'll,
we'll bounce around sort of memento
style throughout your life I think.
But what are some of your earliest,
most formative memories
from your childhood? So I,
my family and I, we were
really close. Um, I have four,
three brothers and one sister
and we were always up to no good.
We live in a small town in Utah and we
had nothing really to do but get into
trouble. But we're also very close
when we were best friends, um,
it was through truth, through a high
school, for example. Most that, you know,
when people are in high school, they
don't like their parents will shun them.
They're embarrassed by them.
But I would walk down the hallways with
my arm around my mom and she'd give high
fives to my friends cause she was there
if, you know, being a substitute teacher,
watching over her rambunctious boys.
But um,
we had a great time as a family and um,
for fun we would watch the Dukes
of hazard and the a team, uh,
on Friday nights and we'd go get
a special combo meal at Hardee's.
We didn't really have much
money, but we just, uh,
I guess I have a lot of sweet memories
from growing up to being close to the
family. And what it sounds like
your mom was one of the cool moms.
What do you think, I correct me
if I'm wrong, but I mean what,
what characteristics of hers or habits
of hers or otherwise enabled her to be
the cool mom and not the shunned
mom? You know, what, what were the
contributing factors? All right.
So one time I wondered what
if you filled a gallon,
a milk gallon jug full of
gasoline and you lit it on fire.
I wondered what would happen.
And so I went out into the street,
and this is just in front of
your house or, yeah, exactly.
I took the gasoline that was otherwise
used for the lawnmower and I filled out
this carton and I went out on
the street and I lit it on fire.
And as expected,
you know,
it was producing quite a flame and
then her green Taurus rolled around the
corner down coming down the street
coming home. And I thought, oh no.
So in haste I kicked over the jug and
now the gasoline spills on the street and
into the gutter and now it's rolling down
the gutter. Uh, and there's cars there.
So I'm having these images of
like cars blowing up, right?
So I walk them to the gutter and I
stomp on the gasoline to put it out.
And of course that splashes.
Now the lawns on fires,
like it's getting worse and worse.
So anyways,
we put the fire out and then the only
thing she says to me, she says, Brian,
you probably shouldn't do that
again. And I said, all right. That's,
that's fair. That's a very,
that's typical. My mom, she
was a supportive and kind.
She kept us out of trouble the best
she could, but she wasn't over the top.
And we responded to that. Do you, so
do you think it was a very Dalai Lama,
like response to potential gasoline
bomb? Uh, do you think, uh,
you know, from the time that I lit the
Dalai Lama's loan on fire, I can say, ah,
I'm kidding. That's not what
I did. But the, the, uh,
do you think then that that kind of
moderation in discipline prevented the
rebelliousness that you would otherwise
see? Or do you think that it was,
that she was closer to you guys in some
way that then other parents were to
their kids?
We trusted her implicitly and I think
when she let go and we owned ourselves and
our own behavior,
I think we behaved accordingly.
And so I did feel responsible for
my own behavior and it didn't,
I was still just as mischievous,
but I also knew there were boundaries
and how mischievous I could be and it was
out of respect for her and that she did
give us a lot of freedom to do what we
wanted to do.
Did you ever get in,
did you get in trouble at school or not
so much so I successfully avoided really
serious trouble my whole life, but, uh,
just below the level that I think
could have been a really dangerous,
but we did all sorts of things.
And um,
even now I guess as I look at
my children as they grow up,
the world has been sterilized dramatically
in terms of what is and is not
acceptable behavior.
Um,
in many ways I'm grateful for the things
we were able to do because we able to
explore and try new things out. But um,
yeah, I stayed out of trouble mostly.
Did you collect anything as good
a baseball cards? Baseball cards.
How long did you collect
baseball cards for? Seven years.
I remember going down to the store
and buying the tops, you know,
25 cards for a dollar 25 and was it,
was it mostly an obsession for you
as a baseball fan? Was it a business?
Was it a combination of that and more?
I just loved having it and
knowing that I had value,
some rare card to show to friends
when they came over. But no,
it was just simply a way to splurge.
I didn't like spending money very much,
but that was the only thing
I've really spent money on. Uh,
were you a popular kid in grade school?
High School?
No. So, well, so in eighth grade
I remember I had these good
friends in my neighborhood.
We were best buddies and I was annoyed
because in school there were these
cliques forming of Jackson's donors
and nerds like these typical things,
how people organize themselves.
And they had these ingroup characteristics
where they would conform with each
other's behaviors and say similar things.
And I was bothered because I
wanted to be friends with everyone.
And so I did this like scrappy big
data analysis where I went out and I
evaluated all the different groups and
the power structures within each groups
because there's always people within the
group to allow new members to join the
group. Sort of the alpha.
Exactly. Border Guard. Yes.
And so I would befriend these
people and I would say like, I'm,
I come in peace and I just want to
be friends. I have no agenda here.
And I became friends. I think honestly
with everyone in the whole school.
I just loved having friends and I love
to dance in between the different groups
because they saw the world so differently,
right. There wasn't just like this,
this mono, um, understanding
the world. And so, um,
I really enjoyed maintaining friendships
and that was my first experience in and
learning like social dynamics
because it wasn't natural for me.
I wasn't good looking, I
didn't have expensive clothes.
My parents, we actually,
we had very little money. I
wasn't funny, I wasn't witty.
I wasn't necessarily super smart.
So I didn't have the natural things
that gets you entrance into that kind of
club. And did, did your analysis,
when you're looking at
say the power structure,
when you went and interacted with the,
whoever it was, the rockers, the stoners,
the skaters, yeah, in the blank,
did you take on sort of
the characteristics of that
group or did you have a,
uh,
did you have a base sort of personality
instead of behaviors that went,
that traveled across the groups?
I just took an interest in them.
I want it to understand how they look
to the world, what they experienced,
what they liked, what they disliked.
I just was, um, sincere and I've,
I've always been curious. And so I
know I didn't try to become like them.
I just wanted to be friends
and understand them. Did you
think of yourself or, let
me rephrase that. When,
when did you first start thinking
of yourself as an entrepreneur?
Um, I think when I, when I kit light,
well I guess I lived in Ecuador for
two years and I came home to the,
to the states. And, uh,
I guess this is probably not the
answer you're looking for, but I,
after living in Ecuador and seeing these
people shackled and extreme poverty and
seeing that they really
didn't have a shot at life,
I came home with this burning desire
that I wanted to spend my life improving,
improving people's lives.
And so I assessed what I could do is
I looked at all the things you find in
college,
like model Un and helping do our
projects in Africa or wherever else.
But nothing really spoke to me.
And so I thought, you know what?
I'll just become an entrepreneur.
I'll build a successful business.
I'll retire by 30 with the abundance
of resources and I'll have a freedom of
time. And then I'll figure out
a way to improve people's lives.
And so I think it really,
at the age of 21 was the first time I
set my sights really on that I can become
an entrepreneur and build something of
value. What gave you that confidence?
So I assessed my skills,
what I was really good at and
I couldn't really find much.
This is when you were at 21 or
was it before that? Okay. Well,
because I wasn't good at necessarily
great at school or science or biology,
I didn't really have any skills in of
note. And so I figured, you know, I,
what I do have is I'm persistent,
I'm determined and I'm smart enough
that I can figure stuff out on the fly.
And so entrepreneurship seems like a good
path for me. And then what was, so you,
so you've decided on the, on the, on
the report card, the skill assessment,
the self audit of life, you're
like, okay, persistence check. Yeah.
Good on tap dancing with
uh, with uncertainty. Yeah.
Check box number two. Uh,
where did you go from there?
So I,
I was trying to find a,
a cell phone and I was really frugal.
I've always been very frugal and I
found this guy in the yellow pages.
I met him at the mall and I bought a cell
phone, those super cheap and he said,
hey,
you look like you're smart and energetic.
Why don't you come sell phones for me?
I'll pay you 40 bucks per activation.
And I thought, perfect. Like I'd never,
I never understood this whole idea that
I would trade 60 minutes of my time for
$8 and 25 cents an hour. I seemed crazy
to me. And so he'd said that to me.
I thought, okay, I'll make 80
bucks an hour. I can do two
per hour. And I said, deal.
So I sold phones for him for two days and
then I was on the porch of this lady's
house and she had screamed two
screaming kids. And I had this thought,
I thought, wait a second, if
I'm selling phones for him,
why can't other cell phones for me?
And I left the sale.
I ran home and I spent almost two
solid days figuring out how to become a
wholesale provider of cell phone service.
And I figured it out and I
started a company and now I,
I changed the commission structure.
So now he's making $300 per activation.
And there was a first company I started
and I hired college students to sell
phones for me and I paid my
way through college doing that.
And when you were first selling to people,
like this woman with the
kid screaming on the porch,
was that like I door knock type of sales
approach or how are you no kidding,
the knock, knock and wipe the feet
on the doormat like I what was,
what was the opening, what was the opening
line when somebody opened the door?
While I was ab testing
the different approaches,
I could walk throughout campus and ask
students, I could walk door to door.
So this was my second day and this was
the data test going up and down the
street. So yeah, it was do
you have a cell phone service?
And if you don't then I've
got a plan for you. Yeah,
so one of the, uh, one of my
very close friends, um, uh,
fantastic systems engineer I started
working with when I graduated from college
and went to mass data
storage startup mass.
At that point it was like five
terabytes, 10 terabytes. Big Deal, right?
Big storage area, network
installation at the time. Uh,
he was so effective as a systems engineer
because he had to do integration,
but he started off as a door to
door encyclopedia salesperson.
That was his first entrepreneurial gig.
So he had to get really,
really good at overcoming objections
and interacting with people socially,
even though he is his sort of
bedrock skill set was technical. Uh,
now did you, so let's see, you have the
cell phones. That was your first business.
Uh,
what happened between there,
and this is obviously a very large,
uh, we're maybe not so large,
but it's a lot happen,
I'm sure between that and Braintree.
But what was the sort of
montage version of that? Well,
the short version is the cell
phone company went remarkably well,
but it was not going to make me
enough money to retire by 30. Right.
So I had to find something bigger.
So I started a voice over Ip company with
three founders and it was just before
Skype and Vonage. And the short of that
is we had the wrong team. Wrong product,
wrong timing. We did, we didn't, sounds
perfect. We did everything wrong now.
But we did have a problem.
We actually built something.
We got customers and this was also in
Utah? Yes. Yeah. And we had revenue side.
We actually built something,
but in reality that we were not
set up to succeed. So that felt,
and then on the heels of that I started,
I joined another guy to do
real estate development.
And the short of that is we that failed
because of some bad decisions we made.
And so without income for
two years I was dead broke.
And so I applied for 60 jobs and found
a monster and the other job sites at the
time, nobody would hire me. Like it was
just, I think it was so clear that I was,
I had no intention of staying a long time.
I tried to make the resume look like it,
but just never was the case.
So now nobody would even
give him an interview and
then write additional skills,
loyalty, fierce loyalty to your
employer. Um, and then I read,
I saw the newspaper one day,
I had a list of the 50 richest
people in Utah and I thought, Bingo,
that's what it is. I will write an email
to these 50 people. I'll say I'm young,
I'm smart.
I,
I'm trying to become an entrepreneur by
just need some money on the side so I'll
be coming right hand, man, I'll
do whatever you want me to do.
And no one responded. It's at this point
I'm like totally desperate. I'm sure you,
I'm sure you get a fair amount
of those emails these days. I do.
And I'm empathetic to it.
Yeah, I totally am. Um,
so at this point I have no income.
I have a child at home and
so I need to make ends meet.
And so I find this job posting in again,
I think it's monster.
It was selling credit card processing
door to door and basically it was like if
you go business to business, yes. Yeah.
Like marching up and down the street,
walking into a retailer or restaurant.
Let me help you set up a merchant account.
Yes. Or get a point of sale
system. Yes. Or mostly change.
Everyone already had existing
service. Got It. Got It. And so I,
the requirement was like if you could fog
a mirror, you can work for these guys.
It's a hundred percent commission.
Like what?
They don't care if you
don't succeed. Right. But
to your point on the sell side, um,
I would go to inside of business,
I figured out pretty quickly the
industry was really messed up.
Like a technology was terrible and um,
people were just generally plagued
by the industry because it's just
unscrupulous all this dishonesty
and complexity. As I figured out,
that was the hook because my
product had zero differentiation.
It was exactly the same as
500 other providers that
walked in the door, you know,
every day. Right. And so I'd walk in, I'd
say, all right, Tim, you saw me walk into,
you'd be like, all right, sales
guy. All right. And not interested.
I've got stuff to do. Then when you
heard me say credit card processing,
it's like, please leave strike too.
Yeah, like leave. So I would say, Tim,
if you give me three minutes of your time,
I will give you $100 if you don't
say yes to using my service.
And usually they'd say like,
okay, that's interesting.
Like what does this guy have to offer?
And I would open my pitch book and I'd
walked him through the industry here,
the providers, here's what to do, here's
what they do it, here's what I do.
I'm the same as everyone else
except with me. You get, you know,
honesty and transparency
and great customer support.
And so I became this company's
number one salesperson.
I broke all their sales records falling
this really simple formula of just
selling honesty and transparency and a
broken industry. That's super interesting.
And uh, so a couple of questions.
I just want to rewind for a second.
With the real estate company, what were,
if you're comfortable talking about them,
like what were the bad decision? What
were the worst decisions? What were the,
the fatal mistakes? So I'm really
proud of actually of what we did.
We launched a $50 million mixed juice
project in one of the best places in Utah.
Makes to use means residential
plus commercial. Exactly. Yup.
Bottom floor of the small
shops and Fannie Mae came in.
They were our equity investor.
We really put together a great project.
The single biggest flaw was storage space.
So empty nesters showed up to buy and
there wasn't sufficient storage and
storage for just all of their extra stuff
that they want it to take out of the
big house and move into exactly
this community living space.
So then sells stalled and phase one,
the bank got anxious,
so got it. So just didn't account
for that. Yeah, that need,
that was the big blunder,
uh, with the sales.
So I'm fascinated by sales because there's
the, the good, the bad and the ugly.
And you often see it within
one industry. Right. And, uh,
so this brings back a lot of
memories for me because I was the,
the lowest paid as base salesperson at
the startup that I worked for out of
college. And they're like, hmm, you're
really persistent. You're in sales,
you're really persistent, you have no
technical background, you're in sales.
Congratulations. And I was like,
ah, okay. Here we go. So smiling,
smiling and dialing.
Yup.
And one of the things I did was
very similar to what you did with,
uh, taking the potential objection.
And putting it right up front,
which was like I'm the same as every
other guy. Yes. Product, different label.
Same thing except for this press,
which was the relationship piece.
And I took a very approach
when I was cold calling,
which I did between like I want to say
like seven and eight and six and seven.
So I avoided the Times that the gatekeeper
would be manning the phones. Yes.
And only called when I thought I could
get the higher ups who had worked longer
hours. But I would, um, I would,
I would do my homework so I could
guess what they were currently using,
like Solaris boxes or whatever
that's right on the industry.
And then I would say, well not sure that
if this is the right fit at all, um,
if you're using this type of system,
the step system or this ties up system,
it is not at all.
Um,
and I would take all of the potential
weaknesses and just put them right up
front. Uh, what you,
you at that point had
already had experience hiring
salespeople. How did you,
what did you look for in salespeople?
Or how did you,
how did you hire the people who have the
highest likelihood of success or train
them, their ability to connect with
other people and earn their trust?
And what are the correlating,
uh,
behaviors or qualities
that allow them to do that?
That they had to be genuine and it,
it couldn't be that they were
manipulating them and to believe in them.
It had to be truthful,
right?
That if I trusted you that you were
saying something that I could believe you
and that would be true tomorrow as well.
So I think that sincerity and
being genuine go a long ways.
And I think even,
you know,
it spans differences of personalities
and experiences in life.
But if someone feels like
someone who's really trustworthy,
and how do you read that when you
meet someone? If I trust them. Okay.
I'm just gonna I'm gonna, I'm gonna dig
a little bit more. All right. So what,
is that a visceral spider sense or is it
a, that guy's not looking me in the eye.
What is the, is it a gestalt
of all those things? What is,
what is it that leads you to feel that
you can trust or not trust someone? Yeah,
I don't know. I guess, um, yeah,
I've always had an interest in people
and makes them curious and I've always
enjoyed friendships and I don't know
if I could even articulate this.
It's just this subconscious process
that happens that I read whatever the
hundreds of data points that you read
when you meet someone and you intuitively
feel like, yeah, I, I could trust this
person. And the more you gather the,
of course, the higher confidence level it
becomes, of course, like I make mistakes.
I can what else? But, um, I
think it's a fairly accurate,
I think most people can read that.
How this works.
This is a bit of a lateral step,
but I just saw,
and I want to say it's called x Makina.
Yeah.
Which made me think of, I guess
it's Deus Ex Machina, which is the,
the machine or God from the machine,
which is when it's a theater expression.
I'm all over the place because I've
had enough caffeine and coconut oil.
But it's,
it's when there was a plot,
a plot problem that needed to be solved
and the writer couldn't find any other
solution besides having like God descend
from the rafters on a wire and be like,
be gone problems. Therefore act three,
it comes to a close good night everyone,
but uh,
x Mokena I think that's,
there's a lot of debate about how
Latin has pronounced but no idea.
And then in case,
how long do you think it is?
And we're in 2015 and last I checked
before it computer can read all of those
micro expressions and so on and come
to the same type of trust or not trust
conclusion.
If you were a betting man
and this was the price is
right. Yeah, with technology,
I don't think I'm qualified to answer.
I will say that
the other day I watched a
video online where robots,
we're walking along and then people were
kicking the robots are tripping them or
doing something to put up an obstacle.
And I had this emotional reaction watching
this happen even though I knew they
were robots.
But watching humans be cruel to robots.
Like if this visceral
reaction inside of me.
And so as you've talked about,
you know,
Xbox net and the progression of robotics
to read our emotions and for us to
interact with them, the
emotions real, right? Like the,
our ability to connect with robots.
As significant as I watch my kids interact
with Siri and even other low tech, um,
you know, computer, the
interfaces, I think that
we will generally be surprised at
how seamlessly the technology's role
throughout society and
how we just interact as we
normally what it will appeal
to our emotions and all
these things we read.
Do you think we will have those are
touring test level interactions with
machines within the next five years?
I find that Betty,
Matt, I'll, I'll go longer.
I'll say I'll say a decade.
At least decade at least.
Interesting. All right. Uh,
did the credit card processing business
or that experience you became the number
one salesperson? Yeah. Uh,
where did obviously very interrelated,
not exactly the same, but how did that,
how did you go from there to bring
tree? I did it for a year. And
it was amazing because it
was this terribly broken
world over the technology you
just was years behind and no one
trusted at a different providers.
It was fragmented with hundreds
of providers. And after doing it,
I thought this is a perfect
industry to start a company.
And so I started Braintree to disrupt it.
So just so ripe for it,
for the right technology and the right
disposition as a company to to be honest
and transparent and treat customers.
So they were thrilled.
And did you have any technical
background? I didn't know it did not, no.
So no computer science? No. No. Mechanical
engineering. Electrical engineering.
What was the, and you had one kid at
home at that point to two kids at home.
So what was the,
do you remember the moment
or the conversation or the
walk in which you decided,
yes,
I'm going to forego this sales job where
presumably you're making pretty good
income and start this company?
Yeah, so we, what I did to start Braintree
is I had these customers in Utah.
I was in Chicago at the Times where I
built Braintree Chicago and I went back to
my 10 best customers in Utah,
best meaning like most loyal and also
making me the most amount of money.
And I said, hey, I just started
this company, Braintree.
I would love it if you switched
over your processing to eat.
And it was restaurants, retailers,
so it was just terminals.
I could use backend processors for it
and I think I had like nine of the 10 say
yes, if I remember right.
And they collected,
we've made me $6,200 a month and it was
enough for me to get going to hire some
part time help and start the company.
And the biggest transition we had,
his open table showed up and they said,
hey,
we have 11,000 restaurants
around the world that we just,
where was open table based California?
It was, yeah. And they somehow found you.
So the cofounder of the
founder of open table,
Chuck Templeton was an advisor and he
knew of the problem they had internally
with,
they had this huge global network of
restaurants and they stored credit card
data when people made reservations
and they had the compliance issue.
And so they came to us and they said like,
we have this big problem and we
said we can fix it. And of course,
like I had no idea if I could fix it,
but we did a deal with them and that's
when we became a software company.
But it was,
it was a bet the company decision.
So in the beginning then Braintree was
like your previous company that you
worked for as a salesperson. It was kind
of a commodity. That's right. Business,
but you had the relationships.
That's right. So,
so at a couple of related questions,
how on Earth as, um, I assume,
but correct me if I'm wrong,
kind of an unknown quantity at that point.
Did you get Templeton as an advisor?
We met at a local meetup in
Chicago and we, what kind of meat?
It was actually Matt Maloney
and Mike Evans from grubhub.
They just went public and, um,
Korangal who was at local entrepreneur,
but there's like five or six of us and
people were just getting together to have
breakfast. And he and I hit it off and
he was clearly a great guy. I mean,
he had the right disposition,
the insights.
He was advising people around the table.
He was an advisor for Matt and Mike at
Grub hub and he came on and he was my
only advisor, uh, for the whole duration
of when I was building Braintree.
No kidding. And, um,
how did you get so connected with the,
these tech guys when you were not,
at least from the first glance
as an outsider looking in,
not in the tech space per
se? Yeah. Or were you,
I don't know. No, I wasn't, I
wasn't connected to software
engineers that at all,
actually.
And so I had one friend who I
trusted as a good developer,
people he a high, you know, he has
a good reputation. And I would make,
I would post jobs online and then,
uh,
he would help me interview
these people as they came in.
And as I listened to the questions
he asked and how he discerned what,
what made a good engineer.
I learned over time how to decipher.
And it took me a couple hires to get
down and then I found a couple of really
good core engineers and I know how to
benchmark to know what exactly to hire
Bolton personality but also coding skills
and we can then build up from there.
And so that's how you developed the,
that's how you sort of got your foot
in the door with the tech world. Yeah,
that's right. And then the, then,
so when I started Braintree, I,
I have three main goals.
One is that I wanted us to be the
best payments butter in the world for
developers too.
That I wanted our employees to say he was
the best company that ever worked for.
And three that our customers
would write us love letters.
And so on the employee side,
I wanted people to literally
go home and rave about work.
To be so excited about the stuff they
were working on and what they did and how
they did it in their peers.
And so having high quality engineer's
was really important because no one likes
to work with someone who is
incompetent or causing a problem.
So it was extremely important.
We got like exceptional people
to work and do any of those,
those questions come to mind?
Kind of high level vetting questions for
good engineers on the technical side.
Sure. There's a lot on the
personality side that, so we would,
what I would try to communicate when we
hired someone was at we payments was not
necessarily changing the world.
It wasn't like we're going to provide
clean water for everyone in the world or
whatever else.
The stadium objective that we were
going to build an exceptional company,
like a company with a soul
that we really cared about.
And so I wanted people who
really cared about what they did,
the quality of the product,
the quality interactions,
working with other engineers. So
we're in it for the longterm. It's,
I try to flush it out and interviews
of we're here to do something epic and
special. So if that appeals
to you, great. If not,
then how do you, now maybe this comes
back to the uh, the spider sense,
but how do you vet people
who are bs singing and acting
in an interview to get a
job versus people who are
the true believers for? Well,
so I guess for non engineers,
I would write this,
these posts on craigslist to recruit
people and at the very top of the page,
so the assumption was first the person
reading your job ad is not the person you
want to hire. That was
the assumption. Yes. Okay.
That the person reading the ad knew
the person you wanted to hire. Ah,
so the very first statement was,
uh,
I will pay you $5,000 if you refer
the most capable person, you know,
and then it's, then below it it
would say, please do not apply if,
and we've list out characteristics of
people who just weren't compatible fire
environment. So we wanted to be
clearly distinctive. And who we were.
And then we had a section that said
please do apply f. And so the goal was,
but the do not apply was
first it was first. Yeah.
Which had this great psychological effect.
And then the police do uh,
apply if we want people to jump
out of their seats and say,
this is the environment
I've been dying to be in.
Because the most exceptional people
love to work with exceptional people and
they have a hard time dealing with
people who are not that exceptional.
And so if you build critical
mass around everyone around you,
it's just really good.
Then it feeds upon itself.
And so we wanted to put
that signal out to say,
if you feel like this
and your current job,
like you're the best guy in
the whole company, Best Gallon,
the whole company and everyone else
around you is kind of driving you nuts.
Like you can come over here and feel
really good about, about, you know,
what you do every day and who you're
working with. How did you choose the name?
Braintree. I, so it's funny
being the small company,
I went through this thought
process of like, Hey,
I'm small and I'm insecure so I'm going
to come up with like national federation
of Merchant Services or using big words
that connotates strength and stability
and nothing felt right.
And I had just read the biography of
John Adams who was born in Braintree,
Massachusetts, and I really admired
John for his contributions to the world.
And so I wanted to come up with a name
that was meaningful to me personally.
And it was Braintree. No kidding. I didn't
realize that. Braintree Massachusetts.
Yeah. Wow. I had no idea. Uh, so you,
so you have this advisor,
open table opens a lot of doors or
changes the direction of the company,
it sounds like.
That's right.
Did it make you nervous that you were
betting the future of the company on
one person effectively?
Who is,
I suppose making promises or
pointing to the future and saying,
this is what we can do together?
Well,
so it was a big decision because I
think I was 28 at the time and I grew up
poor. We knew we'd have any
money. And as an entrepreneur,
of course I had never had any money.
And so I've been broke my
entire life at this point.
We're making really good money.
We were making I think something like,
I dunno if 200,000 of net income a year.
So it was the first time I actually made
money my entire life and deciding to
become a software shop meant we've
pointed back all the cash back into the
business because I was bootstrapping.
I hadn't taken any outside capital and
so it was a huge decision on what to do.
But, um, it was also, I knew that I
intuitively knew the industry is broken.
I intuitively knew that if we
got the right people there,
we could build good software.
And so to me it was a, a Moscow.
Are there any, um, so
you mentioned John Adams.
Are there any, uh, books,
biographies or otherwise that gave you
confidence and I kind of quit spa to go
for it in those early
formative years? Yeah. I,
personal hero of mine is Ernest
Shackleton. Oh yeah. I'll let you,
I'll let you reintroduce people. Yeah,
we probably share a mutual love. Yeah.
So 1914,
he went on to the Trans imperial and
Arctic expedition where he tried to cross
coast to coast,
the South Pole and Antarctica and the,
what I like about Shackleton and there's
a whole bunch of things like my shackle,
the basically to this question is when
he imagined what he wanted to do in the
world, he chose the most
audacious thing imaginable.
At the time it was, it was nearly
inconceivable that somebody could do that.
And he chose to do it and he prepped
and he did it and they failed in their,
in their debit. Right? But
he's not remembered as a
failure. He's remembered as,
as the grit and,
uh,
how they actually overcame all the
obstacles that came about during the
expedition. He's hugely
inspirational in my life because I,
I apply what I call the Shackleton Sniff
test to everything I do in life that I
contemplate if I'm going about on this
endeavor, does it meet the threshold,
the Shackleton applied that,
is this the most audacious
endeavor I could possibly conceive?
And in time we'll iterate, we'll change,
we'll pivot that happens of the course,
but I want to start with
that as the contemplation.
So it's kind of like a a what
would Shackleton do? Bracelet.
Yeah. Yeah. Better said
Shackleton. Uh, why did you move
to Chicago to pursue an MBA?
Oh, no kidding. Yeah. Why did you,
are you glad that you got an Mba?
I have mixed feelings
about it. School, I've,
I was always so bored of school because
I felt like the data rate was so slow as
like a 56 k connection,
right.
Sitting in the classroom and the
pace of speech and the data, it just,
I wanted like a gig data transfer.
It,
I wanted to learn so much faster and so
school, which was boring to me and um,
I mean the NBA Mba was, was
helpful but I don't know, um,
I guess I had learned in different ways,
mostly from doing and I'd been in the
trenches of entrepreneurship my whole life
and that's really how I prefer to learn.
Then of course,
reading on my own and stuff like that.
Let me ask you this.
If you were counseling a
young entrepreneur who was
living somewhere they felt
was, and I'm not saying you
taught us this place cause I've,
I've actually spent quite
a bit of time there,
but if they're living somewhere they
feel doesn't allow them to surround
themselves with other,
uh, highly ambitious,
capable entrepreneurs.
Yeah.
And the only way that they could relocate
was to get an MBA say to Chicago,
New York Sf. Yeah. Uh,
do you think the hundred and 20 k or
whatever it might be would be worth it
if someone, if someone, if one of your
kids was considering getting an Mba? Yeah.
And let's just say they were kind
of of that age now. Yeah. What,
what might you ask them or,
so I remember the very first case study
we did in school was about these guys
who were the Kim Up,
I think of the new new golf ball
that was better than the golf balls.
And it was about their struggle over
two year period of time to work through
patents and Ip and all get distribution
channels and stuff like that.
And then we got together with the
study group to talk about the case.
And there were certain questions
we are trying to answer,
I forget what they were,
but in my group with our five of us and
we had contemplated things like cost
models and distribution channels and
my mind immediately went to like,
how have these people paying for their
rent, other marriage is still intact,
right? Like are they emotionally
just too stressed out to function?
The way I thought was sewing was,
was uh,
so colored by my experience as an
entrepreneur and it was such a dramatic
difference in how my peers thought.
Uh, people coming in from like Ernst,
Ernst and young to logical operations,
yeah. Make their pay grade dramatic.
And so I guess I would say to my son
that the skills you need to succeed in a
certain track of life may
not require that education,
that the course out of persistence and
determination and then just the ability
to learn and adapt quickly are much
better suited for trying to do this.
And it doesn't have to say
that education is not helpful.
The certainly isn't certain regards, but
there are different types of education.
That's right. Yeah. What's
the most valuable thing you
took from business school
or from that experience?
Let me say that.
We can come back to it. Yeah.
You're giving me the look
or we can drop it. I'm not
sure. Okay. Well that's,
that's, that's fine answer. Uh,
I think more people should have that as
an answer. Quite ab. That is the answer.
Uh, I was telling my brother were
talking about some really kind of deep
philosophical questions and I said, I
just haven't figured it out. And he said,
maybe that's what you figured
out. Exactly. Totally true.
Maybe that's not an answer
you need to find. Um, so with,
with brain tree then let's,
let's kind of look at, uh, what,
what turned rain tree into
a rocket ship or what was,
what led to that perception at the
very least. So I am already on,
I had to figure out how to get
customers without any money,
which is a hard problem to solve
carbon problem. Right, exactly.
And so what I did is I, I
knew that computers, you know,
computer software engineers were the
target that I needed to appeal to them.
And I knew there were different
communities like python.net ruby on rails,
Java,
they all hung out in the different
committees and each community had certain
characteristics about how they work
together, how collaborative they were,
how chatty the war.
And my theory was if I
could find a community of
engineers that were chatty and
that helped each other through a word of
mouth referral basis and I could get a
few of the leaders in that
group to come on board,
then it would spread throughout the
community and then we'd go to adjacencies.
And so I did this analysis of looking
at the characteristics and I found that
ruby on rails was the most conducive,
that they were very tight net.
Did you figure this out by
looking at message boards?
How did you go about doing it? No,
I found actually a couple of sites,
academic research papers that yeah,
that actually measured sociability and
interconnectedness and had like these
maps, the diagrams that showed
what these nodes were and who,
how they inter connected.
And then I focused on Ruby on rails and
we've got a couple liters in there like,
you know, 37 signals and a few others
get hubs. Good one, hang on, get.
Jason and David were amazingly good to us.
Like they would tweet out all the time
and they refer it out. All their friends,
they were fantastic.
And so we basically built a business
on word of mouth because, uh, we,
we tried so incredibly hard
to be exceptional. We did.
So they come on and they would love it,
what we will be built and how we
treated them and they would tell others.
So I want to do, I want to really
underscore what you just said
because I think it's so important for
anyone who's considering launching a
product or service or business.
And that is that the,
your first target is not
the entire market. Right.
And when I talk to people
about say book launches,
a lot of people want everyone to love
the buck and when they write and promote
and market a book to appeal to everyone.
When everyone,
when you want everyone to
be your customer, customer,
no one is your customer,
especially when you have no money,
you need the kind of cost per
acquisition to be as low as pos, right?
Ideally zero.
And uh,
so when I launched you the four hour
workweek or is formulating the marketing
plan,
I mean you and I have a lot of shared DNA.
We've observed this before
because a lot of different areas,
but I wanted to identify the market I
could communicate with that would have
the,
the highest rebroadcasting ability and uh,
very much actually similar to your,
your chattiest checkbox. Right.
And I determined that I always want it
to be a market that I understood ideally
belonged to.
And that was the kind of 20 to 35 year
old tech savvy nails and San Francisco,
New York. Right. Primarily.
And, um, and then after, if I,
if I hit a critical mass in that,
in that particular
demographic and psychographic,
say my goal was I think it was 10,000
bucks per week for two weeks and I could
try to identify kind of the conversion
rates and so on to hit that number,
then I knew through word of mouth that
would bleed out both an age range.
It would jump from male
to female. Exactly. Uh,
but I wanted to identify the people who
are kind of disproportionately creating
the most online content exactly.
At that time. Yep. And um, okay,
so you target ruby on rails and uh,
was there a particular tipping point
where you were like, holy Molly.
Okay. Well any, any,
any particular kind of hockey stick or
breakthrough moments that come to mind?
Yeah, so we, let me think.
So we got as customers within the
first couple of years, um, yeah,
37 signals get hub, Uber, Airbnb,
living social when they were on
their tear. And we had so many,
do you have the All star team?
We did.
We had some of the best companies in
the whole world using us and that their
growth fueled of credibility,
of course in our brand that we are
able to provide great services to them.
So we had this exceptional client
base. That's, that's what it was,
is once these guys hit their
growth trajectories, right.
And then once the reputation started
spreading that we were a great provider,
people loved using our service,
they just really built upon itself.
Who were you in that period
of time competing against?
Who are your primary competitors?
Initially it was the old guard,
like cybersource and authorize.net and
then processors like first data and
global,
uh,
which were really great targets because
they were dinosaurs and technology. Um,
and then stripe launched, uh, I
think about a year or two after us.
And they're obviously a fantastic
company and so they became formidable
competitors. Um, and then of course
paypal is always there, right.
Doing their thing. And so when,
when you met with the Uber's,
the airbnbs and so on,
how did you convince them to work with us?
Um, many. So we did do some outbound,
like we did track a lot
of these companies down,
but most of these companies sign up on
their own that we just found out they
were customers when they were
going through the underwriting
process. Um, but we,
we did, we did target some of
these companies individually,
but most of it was organic.
Got It. And what do you,
to what do you,
aside from the word of mouth,
what are other things that facilitated
them finding you natural naturally?
The being exceptional that I, this was
the thing I said continually again,
it again internally is that
if we paid attention to
creating an environment where
people who interacted with,
interacted with us would walk
away and say unbelievable, right?
The software's amazing.
The support is amazing.
That I just love this company and I so
much so that I wanna write them a love
letter.
If we solve that,
everything else will take care of
itself because they'd walk away.
And in Catholic in that night when they're
out with their friend getting to bear,
they're gonna bring us up because they
had this amazing experience with us where
we solved all the problems and we did
small things like we would the integration
team,
we would see when someone's coating to
the API and if they were having problems
with it, we'd reach out and say, Hey,
like we see your code into the
API and the Kevin Problems, uh,
can we help if what? Like who does that?
Like who, who proactively reaches out.
So we tried to do small things at credit.
He's really great experiences for people
that could you explain just for people
who are non technical out there?
So application programming
interface equal, yeah,
sorry. Yeah, no, no, no. We're,
we're fine. I love to kind of, uh,
it's a very important concept right
in, in a lot of tech. So what,
what does coding to the API mean?
So they are programming their software
to speak to our software and there was a
certain way that they would do that.
And so there's a lot of the value
of how that's done. Would be,
is our software easy to work
with? Does that make sense?
You know, it's just, yeah.
And so your software is,
is behind the scenes. Yeah.
Handling transactions. So it's kind
of like you have in a restaurant,
front of the house,
the Maitre d of the waiters and so on.
Then you have back of the house,
the restaurant, and you need those.
The people in the restaurant never see
the people on the back with all the
flames and cuts out on them.
You need a very reliable way for the
front of the House to talk to the back of
the house. Exactly. That's the API.
That's right. Uh, and it's super,
super important concept. It's how
also, I mean, correct me if I'm wrong,
it's how a lot of companies grow very
quickly just by making that a seamless,
that's right. Experience. Yeah.
Making your services broadly available
to a broader ecosystem of engineers. It,
um,
your story reminds me of a story told
by one of my favorite people out there.
A guy named Derek Sivers. I don't
know if you know Derek. So Derek is a,
uh, it certainly hope to have
him on the podcast sometime,
but sort of a philosopher
king in the programming world,
a really fascinating guy, great
teacher, also really great teacher.
But he
had a very similar focus
on details with CD baby,
the company that he started grew and
then later sold. And uh, I remember he,
he told me, and he wrote about this in
his book as well. And if you guys search,
I think I put this on my blog.
If you just search search Derek
Sivers letter and then Ferris,
I'm sure it'll pop up. Sivers, s I v
e r s sivers.org. Really Amazing Guy.
But when people would get
their order confirmation email,
it was just hilarious.
Kind of elaborate story of like your CD
has been carefully pulled off the shelf
and placed on a satin pillow and then
wrapped in paper by a Japanese origami
specialist. And it was this
just very personable, uh,
email confirmation and no one was
doing that. Yes. And so it, it spread,
it was such a small detail with,
with huge implications. Yup. Uh, for,
for a brand loyalty, for Pr, for us
acquisition, for all of these things.
And it was so easy to do. Yup. Right.
It was not something that
a big company couldn't do.
It was just something a big company
wouldn't do. Yes, typically. Right.
What are other, uh, what are
other, um, whether it's, I,
and I hesitate to use this
term, but growth hacks or, uh,
say, uh, rituals,
routines or rules in within Braintree
that allowed you guys helped you guys grow
as quickly as you did?
It's a one we, one thing I focused
on a lot was the second goal,
which was that employees would say it was
the best place they've ever worked and
it was this ongoing quest to figure
out how to make that happen. Again,
my goal in my mind was they go home and
rave about what they do on a daily basis.
They feel good in life, that they love
it. And so I always wanted to know what,
what people were feeling and thinking
because if I didn't know that,
then I couldn't change or, or
build, you know, certain things.
And so I tried all the normal things of
like we did town halls every week and it
was more like group therapy than it was
company updates where I would let these
long awkward silences persist until like
the fain came up though everyone was
worried about or what they want
to talk about, but no one dared.
So what would be an exam?
When would those awkward pauses come?
I would say it does it does. Anyone have
any questions and you just let it sit?
Exactly like we're going to,
we're going to wait until we have some
questions and like I knew there's like
one or two things on everyone's
mind because I could feel
the pressure build all
week. Right? I mean the
one thing I learned is pink
elephant expanding. Exactly.
The thing is true in life is that everyone
always has a pebble in their shoe,
always.
Right?
There's something bothering us and that
sometimes by just acknowledging it,
it take,
it addresses the problem.
But it seemed like every week we'd built
up this tension in the startup, then we,
you know, in the company and
if we addressed it openly
in the town hall setting,
it would be great.
And so I would look as long pauses go and
someone would find that was a hand and
see like,
all right,
like I'm really bothered that we
hired someone for this role instead of
promoting some of them internally.
Right? Like what's going on? Right.
And it was great because you have
a really hard question to answer.
And so I encourage like brutal honesty
back and if they criticized me even
better, right? If they could criticize me
than anything, it was full up and game.
But one thing I,
I,
I was at this Christmas party one year
and I was talking to the significant
other of one of my employees,
this was added company Christmas
party company Christmas party.
We're in the buffet line and I say,
so like, how's you know, stolen.
So doing like he, he's four months
in and how's he enjoyed life?
And she says like, it's amazing. Like,
he is happy and I, he comes home and he's
energized and he loves his coworkers.
And it's so different from what he
was, how he felt before. And I thought,
yes,
like this is the data I want.
I cause I want to know
the significant other,
knows the most about how that person
feels in life based upon what they do on a
daily basis.
And so it was a constant quest of trying
to find out the right data source of
how people feel in life to
build an exceptional company
and knowing where to go
for that data, how to get
it. And now of course,
like I couldn't go interview everyone
all the time. That would be awkward.
But just knowing that the data sources
are out there to gather, to build,
you know, a good team was really
helpful. So you said, you know, if they,
if they criticize me all the better, what
would you, how would you prompt people?
To be brutally honest, because you're the,
you're the big boss, right? Right. Uh,
would you send out an email outlining the
goal of the town hall or would you get
up and talk for a few minutes in the
beginning and try to encourage people to
let that stuff out? What, what, what
did you say in either case? So one,
I think it's a,
a disposition I tried to
be self deprecating where
I would make fun of myself
for things I did or mistakes I had made.
I tried to open the broadcast those so
that they felt comfortable that I owned
up and I wasn't, you know, sensitive
about it. And then I would just, um,
I guess in dialogue I would
try to typically own things
myself and to make them
feel comfortable that they could
bring it up. We can discuss it openly.
How would you do that? So
if we talked about, um,
I'm trying to think of like a
recurring theme that came up. Um,
maybe if it came up like two or three
times I can say like, look like this.
Honestly,
he's like my deal because you guys have
brought this up two or three times now.
I've not done something
about it that's adequate.
So clearly I'm not doing what I should
be doing because you're doing your job of
being honest and transparent with me.
I have not taken the responsibility
of actually acting on this.
So I'm going to go think about this,
put together a plan and do up in the
meantime like this is my problem and my
mistakes. So I'd tried to own
things like that. So it's not,
it's no longer your job to worry about it.
It's my job to worry about that.
Like I hear you.
You did a good job.
Thank you for being honest and transparent
because that's what I asked of you.
And you don't have the
power to fix that yourself.
This is like a more community
problems. So it's in my, so the,
um, the observation I've had
on multiple occasions and, um,
is, uh, you're very persuasive, but I
don't think you'd be very good at lying.
And I could be, maybe you're so good
that I would never notice. I don't know.
But I'm, I'm making, I'm
just kidding, obviously,
but I don't think you'd be good at lying.
And you seem,
even though you don't
have technical training,
you seem very scientifically minded
and sort of an engineer at heart.
Does that make sense?
I mean you,
you're very methodical and one thing
that I've personally struggled with is,
Eh, maybe this is through a
lot of competitive sports.
Maybe it's just from being
a working solo so often,
uh, I don't want, I generally don't
want, or it's a personality type.
I don't want people to
tell me what's going right.
I want the bad news because I feel like
the good news we'll take care of itself.
Does that make sense? Yeah. And
I think as a result of that, uh,
I recognize that one of
my kind of deficiencies
as a manager of people is that I'm
not very good or consistent in giving
positive feedback.
Uh,
I don't feel like I erroneously believe
that because I don't necessarily need
that other people probably don't get it
right or I just forget about that. Yup.
Uh, how, how did you address that
within brain tree? Because I think it's,
at least in my experience,
it is important, uh, to
maintain morale of the troops.
And so on. Uh, what did you do to
help kind of maintain morale and,
and that level of happiness that the
significant other, yeah, important.
I would tell stories, I would tell stories
about people and exceptional efforts.
Now it's always a double edged sword
because if you tell a story about one
person, you're not telling a
story about the other person.
And one person that was in it,
Phil left out because like I
was just involved as you know,
him or her and doing this. And so, um,
it is tricky, but I, I always highlight,
we did,
I did a weekly emails as well and I want
it to tell stories that people who went
above and beyond the call of duty,
I either in building our software or
a customer service interaction or even
helping a coworker do something. And those
stories resonated with people, right?
They saw with their peers were doing and
it was influential in how they behaved.
So I wanted to build a culture of a
certain behavior and I told stories to
reinforce that right at the positive
written for us. And you did.
How often did he do the
town hall meetings? We did
either weekly or biweekly.
We kind of fluctuated over the years. What
Day of the week or Friday? Friday? Yeah.
Why Friday?
It's a different vibe in the company.
People are kind of reflecting upon the
week. Um, the tension is kind of built up.
We're going into the weekend, Monday
mornings, a little bit frantic Friday.
I find people are more pensive
and reflective and that
it was a good time for us
to dig deep and find out what was really
bothering us and how and re and I guess
regroup on the essence of why we existed.
Right.
That if we weren't just
there to make a paycheck,
we were there to build
something exceptional and to
continually talk about that
was important.
When you were building brain tree,
when do you feel like you were at your,
your seek powers?
In other words,
like when were you pitching a
no hitter in the world series?
Like at what point in building
brain tree was, I don't
think I could identify it.
It was just so gradual.
And over time that we started these
companies like Uber and Airbnb,
they hit their growth stride and it was
amazing that we were powering all their
payments and um,
it was just so gradual and slow because
companies come on brand new and it takes
them a couple of years to ramp up to SAR
processing, you know, significant cells.
So I don't know if I could identify
a single point. It's just this slow,
steady build. When were you under the
most, when did you feel under the most
pressure?
Always. Okay. So the, the, the, uh,
where I'm trying to lead this is
when,
when you can try to think of when you
were operating at a very high level,
under very high stress.
What did your morning routine look like?
The first say hour of your day
or 10 hours of your day. Okay.
Yeah. So I guess if I think about the
broader context of life, I mean, I had
two children when I started brain
tree and then, um, you know,
I had three by the end and we had
my first two children with colicky.
So they're crying all night and so not
be able to sleep very well at night and
get into the next day and going to work.
And the Dylan with all
the stuff you deal with,
it was a pretty tough time in life.
And um,
I mean there were some
dark moments. It's, it's,
I guess something you and I have talked
about on our walks is that I generally
view advice.
I'm very skeptical of advice because
it's so contextual and it can be
deceptively um,
unhelpful because you don't understand
what's packed into that advice.
But one piece of advice I think
is helpful for entrepreneurs,
I wish someone would have told me is the
importance of surrounding yourself with
fellow founders, people who get
you and understand you. Right?
That all those years as a founder, I felt
like I owned everything. I owned energy,
I own growth, I own the success.
It was all me and I had,
it didn't have any cofounders of,
so there's not to say people,
my team didn't shoulder that bright.
But as the founder you deal
fill an a extra level of burden.
And I had no outlet for it.
I owned energy at home.
I owned energy at work and it
did, it was tough. It took a toll.
And so over the past couple years, I have
critiques, friendships, like, you know,
like, like you and I have
where we can talk as if we
were journaling. Right, right.
I mean, to get to the real raw
and good stuff of life. But, um,
I think that that would have been very
helpful during the dockers times during
the theme, the moments where it
was the hottest. Yeah. I, um,
had a, a book inscribed
reaction. It's right there.
The psychedelic explorer's guide
had Jim Fadiman on the podcast and,
uh, I thought it was, inscription
was so great. He said, uh, you know,
to Tim a companion on the path. And I was
like, that's, yeah. And I think, I mean,
we're literally companions on the path.
Yeah. We go on these hikes, but having
those people who can identify with the
pressures that you're feeling. Yeah.
What were other coping strategies that
you had or routines that were helpful
when you felt you were shold
shouldering all of that burden? Yeah,
so I always look for hobbies
that would consume my mind,
where I could escape myself because these
things, you could change the channel.
Exactly. Yeah. For a brief
period of time. Totally.
Because it's like it loops and loops
and loops and if you try anything else,
it just loops. Even when you're
having conversations and I cured,
is obsessed with trying
to build your company.
And so one day I had a hard day at
work and I was walking home. I thought,
you know what? I'm going to go fly an
airplane. Like maybe that'll do the trick.
And I did this discovery flight and
the guy took me up and he's like,
if you can do the following things,
you can fly.
And he did like this really hard turn up
and down. I got sick and I was like, oh,
I can never do that.
So crazy and hard.
But I thought about it the next morning
I thought, no, I can actually do this.
And so I started flying and I lost
myself in aviation. I absolutely love it.
And so that really helps that I could
find a different place to park my mind.
And focus is,
is a discovery flight where like you're
in the passenger seat of a new car and
they show you what the car can do.
Is that what a discovery flight is?
It basically, yeah, you
go up and he's like, hey,
so if you want to get your license, you
have to perform the following maneuvers.
Like here's a steep turn,
you know, 30 degrees. And,
and so he was just showing me basically
how the plane operator and what I would
need to do.
And I think for a lot of people listening,
they think of learning to fly as a
very, very, very, very expensive thing.
I think they associate it with say,
owning a private jet.
But that is not the case. Right. I mean,
as far as I understand that, I mean,
I have friends who work jobs here
who have gotten into aviation. Yeah.
He is it, uh, how,
how cost prohibitive is it to become
involved with aviation? In some capacity.
So I think I paid a few thousand dollars
over the course of the lessons. Got It.
Something like that. Over what period
of time? I believe it took me 90 days.
Got It. So I mean, all in all,
not pocket change but not like
buying a Gulf stream. That's right.
Uh, this is something I've, I've, I've,
I've a number of friends here, uh,
in the bay area who use aviation is
their way of changing the channel,
right? So they're not
constantly watching sort of yes.
BBC News or whatever the hell their
world happened. That's right. Um,
let's see. The, um, when you were 21,
I think you said 21,
when you were 21,
and you thought of the word successful,
who is the person who came
to mind at that point for you
were in that rough range?
I admired people who had,
I guess I had a number of buckets
in my mind of who I admired.
But one bucket that appealed to me because
I thought I could potentially be like
them,
was those who had acquired significant
amount of resources and through building
businesses. And we're now using those
resources to do good in the world,
that they had freedom of time,
they didn't need to show up for a job
and they didn't write all that kind of
stuff.
And so I identified with that because
I think I thought it matched up with my
potential skill sets and something
I could potentially achieve in life.
So it really,
it was freedom of time to do the things
that you could about the most in life.
So who were,
who were some of those people are,
who are some of those people growing
up in Utah? Jon Huntsman was,
I don't know who that, so he built, um,
I'm not even sure what company he built,
but he was enormously wealthy. And of
course the Marriotts are on there as well.
But there were a few families in
the community that had accumulated a
significant resources and they,
they like one,
I think Huntsman has a cancer institute
at the University of Utah and others
that they able to move the needle in
significant ways that other people just
couldn't.
And I thought that was a,
I thought that was really remarkable
that you could make huge contributions
potentially to humanity.
So this is,
this is actually I think a good segue
to one of your current projects.
I think it's fair to say primary projects,
the Os Fund.
It is. Yep. So could you explain to
people what the Os Fund is? Yeah,
so the context is I guess at 21 I made
that goal that I wanted to spend my life
improving people's lives.
And over the 14 years or so as
I was building my companies,
I thought a lot about this.
Like what would it look like,
what would it feel like,
what it tastes like, what
areas, what I focus on?
And I looked through thousands
and thousands of ideas and uh,
I mean I was always thinking about it
and I studied during that time a lot of
about science and technology.
And the realization that I came to is
that the reason why our time and place is
so unique and the arc of humanity is we
literally now have the tools to build
the kind of world we can dream of. So if
you take computer software and biology,
genomics, AI, virtual
reality, three d printing,
we can literally program our existence.
So I think oftentimes if like Davinci
where he had his great sketchbooks,
where he designed a flying machine
and then these really amazing ideas,
but he couldn't build it.
He didn't have the tools.
We can literally build anything today.
And so as I realized that,
I thought this is like the one of the
biggest moments in the history of mankind
or humankind.
How do we,
the biggest question for me was what
kind of world are we going to build?
And that's when I started the Os Fund is,
is trying to invest in these tools of
creation that will still dramatically
effect the kind of world we build.
Yeah,
it is really a fascinating time.
And we were able to sort of a Cambrian
explosion of potential where you know
what, what happens when you
can create virtually anything.
You can download a recipe for a,
an a, a virus that could cause an epidemic
that's right. Or weapon. That's right.
Or at the same time
obviously use that knife,
that surgical knife to repair or
build as opposed to damage. Right.
Uh, what now? Oh, s refers
to operating system. Yes.
Why operating system?
So it's a metaphor I like a lot
that the biggest changes in history,
the biggest improvements in history have
happened at what I call the operating
system level.
So for example,
like germ theory that we tried to figure
out what was causing disease and death
for a long time.
And when we figured out there was this
thing like bacteria that cause infections
and death.
And then once we figured out sterilization
and antibiotics and vaccines and good
personal hygiene,
we radically extended healthy human life.
But it was finding out there was this
core problem of bacteria and every major
change we've had have,
it has been at this level.
And so instead of playing with things
out of different level, um, my,
what we think about is the companies
we invest in are doing world changing
things at the operating system level.
So if they're successful in
their endeavors, it would
radically change the world.
We're in sort of the foundational that's
right level upon which everything else
does. Right? So just like a computer
has an operating system at its core,
the determines how it works and
there's applications that sit on top,
everything in life has an
operating system. And what,
what are some of the investments that
you've made thus far in the Eos Fund?
Yeah, human longevity, uh,
led by Craig venter is they're trying
to radically extend healthy human life,
you know,
into the hundreds and they're doing it
by using the whole human genome and then
adding data like the metal
biome and phenotype data.
And then using advanced machine learning
to learn about disease and create
personal therapeutics.
If they're successful,
it would change a medicine as we know it.
And it really is fundamental way. Yeah.
Uh, any others? Uh, yeah,
we just made an investment
in a gingko bioworks,
which they're basically
making biology programmable.
So just like we use computer code today
to render a website or process a credit
card transaction or fly on
autopilot system at an airplane.
We can program the same
thing in biology for today.
They're doing fragrances and flavors.
The producing in a lab,
the otherwise would be required in nature.
And as we climb up the complexity scale,
we can do much more
complicated things like um,
work on antibiotic resistance and
Carbon Capture. But the idea, Tim,
like your biology, I'm biology,
our world runs on biology, right?
The fact that this could be a programming
language we could actually predictably
use is remarkable. Right? Well, what does
it, I mean, I guess DNA is what Atcg,
right?
I mean it's something along those lines.
Some of them getting out of my depth here
under the my ignorance pool and pretty
quickly, but the, uh, to
the fragrances for instance,
that would be considered, is that
considered synthetic biology? No.
So they design the organism just like you,
you take yeast for brewing beer, right?
Um,
you take an organism and you can alter
within the production that organism,
what it produces.
So it's actually a natural in production.
You're just altering the
organism that produces it,
so it's not synthetic
biology. Interesting. Okay.
So you're just kind of removing a few
ingredients in a preexisting recipe and
letting kind of the chef
he's Africanism yes.
So let's take those different food
product. Exactly. It's this new
era of industrial engineering where it's
going to change all the processes we
created during the first
industrial revolution.
Now what is your, and you may not
have a strong opinion here and if not,
that's totally fine, but
people get, uh, very, uh,
excited, positively and negatively
about, uh, the term Gmo. Yeah.
Uh, and genetically modified food.
Uh, what is your perspective on that?
So I think that because I
just from personal cause
yeah. A personal standpoint,
there are cases where they can change
the genetics slightly to make something
say more resistant to that's
right. Pests. That's right. Uh,
then we, there their start, I,
it seems like we get into an area also
where they're taking something from like
a fish and putting it into a
plant or something like that. Yes.
And then I get a little uneasy and I'm
not sure if that's well founded or not.
Yup. Uh, because if we start getting
into, uh, you know, I think of all of the,
um,
all of the,
sort of a horrifying mad scientist novels
that I read when I was a kid. Yeah. Uh,
but do you think any of those
fears are well founded or,
or what are the risks of that going wild?
Okay.
So I'll answer your question
in a different way. Perfect.
You may not find satisfactory,
but I think it was a very,
very poorly worded question. So thank
you for saving my ass in the first place.
So if we start with this premise that we
have these incredibly powerful tools of
creation, we can program anything.
Okay? That obviously means, and,
and couple that up with,
we have this distributed environment
now where anybody can pull the computer
terminal and anyone in the car in the
world and whatever age and program, right?
Either through biology
or computer software.
So we have all these tools so we have
a world full of makers to have these
powers. So with that, what you build
affects me and what I build affects you.
And so one thing that I'm exploring now
with Eos Fund is what I call societies
are social operating systems.
And there are systems of
cooperation and reconciliation.
So in that category falls like governance
and capitalistic systems, right?
These belief and value frameworks that
drive our behavior and allow us to
reconcile our differences.
So we're going to have some really big
questions to answer and we have to decide
as a society through our
reconciliation systems,
do we modify our genetics and our
children? Do we do GMO? Right?
What is appropriate for AI in
terms of what people build?
So we have really big questions to answer.
And uh,
I think that one of the best areas we
could focus on would be how these social
operating systems are constructed and
calling attention to them as being
technologies that can in fact be
built, changed and, and, and, um,
better aligned with the
realities of our current time.
The big question topic is a really
fascinating one to me for a whole host of
reasons.
I remember as an undergraduate,
some of my favorite classes
were philosophy classes,
introduction to metaphysics or whatever.
And you had say,
utilitarian philosophers.
I think that's the right term.
Like Peter Singer for instance,
very controversial.
I think most of his controversies,
unearned, I think it's
a politicized and so on.
But you know,
the question of doing the greatest
good for the greatest number of people,
how do you make decisions if that's
your objective? Right. And a,
that would mean if there's like you're
stuck in a cave and there's one fact I
plugged in the exit and
they're 10 people in the cave,
we're going to starve to death.
That's right. You killed the fat guy.
I mean just it's mathematics,
pure and simple. Um,
and that used to be primarily
just a thought exercise,
sort of an academic ivory
tower thought exercise.
And now you have companies working
on say, autonomous vehicles. Yup.
And Ai hiring philosophers to
try to advise that's right.
How to answer these questions when say
an autonomous car is barreling down the
highway or the Golden Gate Bridge. And
all of a sudden it has to choose between,
you know, hitting the five, uh, you
know, octogenarians in the sidewalk,
the old ladies or swerving
the other direction and
hitting a car that has a four
year old. Yes, yes. So how do you make
those value judgments, right? Yep.
And what I'm so curious
about, number one, that's a,
that's a very multifaceted,
thorny,
potentially subjective question to tackle,
but you have to program these vehicles
are entities that's right to behave.
That's, that's, that's the, you know,
the set of rules. They're programming.
At the same time, what I really
worry about and, uh, is not,
not only the, the complexity of
the technology on its own is,
is a, is a, is a big audition.
A sort of big audacious challenge
and problem to tackle right by.
Good. Let's just say, Eh,
sort of ethically wired,
uh,
technicians and technologists in
the valley and elsewhere, right?
That's challenging in and of itself,
but how do you address the
ultimately a lot of say these,
whether it's like a bill of rights
or an arbitration agreement to,
to manage these social contracts
where everyone's a maker yes.
Will be dependent on it would seem,
and I want you to challenge me on this,
if you don't agree with this,
uh,
would be dependent on
legislation and there will be
sort of the, the way that Sh,
you know, economics is how humans among
other things respond to incentives. Right?
Right, right. It's like the reward
in a capitalist society say,
and then the punishment of a love
legal system. Yes, exactly. Yup.
When politicians,
many politicians are
completely incentivized in
the short term for reelection
and not envisioning the longterm
implications of some of these massive
decisions. That's right.
Massive decisions. How do
you contend with that? Like,
or how have you, how have you thought
about this? That's why I, it's such a
hugely important area to focus because
when people make decisions, you're
looking to really at the surface layer,
but the beliefs and values that are
driving that are embedded very deeply,
right. Oftentimes that's why
it, that's why, for example,
like social operating systems
are so incredibly powerful,
but also they're invisible.
Like they just are woven into the fabric
of our lives and we don't know they
exist.
And when we do see them as existing,
we just consider them as givens are fixed.
And so what we're hoping to do is
to call attention to what they are,
right. These massive, powerful influence
in our life that drive our decisions.
And we don't even know it. Right.
But our subconscious, exactly. Yep.
And that identifying them that they
really are social technologies that are
driving these decisions. And so if we go
to use, I guess a technical, you know,
turn,
like if we go deeper in the stack,
if we go down to the
operating system level,
like what are these core beliefs in
these core values, where they come from,
what are they assuming? Yeah.
What are the assumptions?
And the if then is that are built
into the lowest level. Exactly.
That affect our decisions on, you
know, the eighth layer. Exactly.
And we've never tracked it back to that
low level because maybe we absorbed them
during childhood through sac
religion that wasn't of our choosing,
whatever it might be.
We're over choosing for that matter.
How do you personally try to identify as
those for yourself in your own personal
decision making and so
on? Yeah, so at Braintree,
one of the principals I consistently
communicated was challenged all
assumptions.
And the story that I accompanied with
it was there's five monkeys in a room,
there's a basket of bananas at the top.
And the monkeys of course,
want to climb the ladder to get the
banana. But every time a monkey tries,
they're all sprayed with cold water.
And so after a few times be sprayed
by cold water, the monkeys learn,
don't climb up the ladder to get the
bananas can we get sprayed by cold water?
And so they take one monkey out and put
a new monkey in and the new monkey of
course sees a bananas. It's like, Hey,
like I'm going to go grab a banana.
But when it tries to go up the ladder,
the other monkey grab it and pull it back.
Like, I don't wanna get sprayed by
cold water. You're a new guy here.
So like don't mess with,
teach you the rules. Exactly.
So then they systematically pull
every monkey out, um, and have you,
and now you have five new monkeys in.
Anytime a new monkey comes in
and tries to climb the ladder,
they grabbed the monkey,
pull it back.
But none of the five have
ever been sprayed by cold
water I've ever experienced.
Exactly. And so what I was trying to
wonder is, where is that in my life?
Like what am I assuming that isn't
visible that I cannot see? And uh,
of course, when the circumstances
change in a situation like that,
you have learned helplessness, right?
Or they would say, take a, I mean,
these are horrible experiments,
but ultimately the data,
I think it's very valuable
where they would have say a,
I think it's a Skinner box.
It was used where they, uh,
subject to animals to shocks.
Yeah.
And there some animals who could move
from one side to the other and avoid the
shock, you know, from a pain
on the floor to another pain.
And then others would
get shock no matter what.
And then if they moved them into a new box
where that was no longer the case,
where they could avoid the shock that
those who had learned it was futile to try
to move, would just lay on the
floor. Yes. And get shocked. Yes.
So where does that exist in your
own life? Uh, what, what have you,
what are some cases if you're
comfortable discussing them,
where you've discovered that,
whether it brain tree in a business
capacity or otherwise? Yeah,
let me think about that.
Um, so many, I mean, I guess
being human is remarkably tough, right?
You get, we just, so like you and I,
before this discussion we were talking
about all the funny, irrational things.
You and I both do inconsistent with
our thought patterns, right. And, uh,
I guess I it a couple of years back,
maybe a decade ago,
I got into irrational behavior reading
Dan Ariely's book predictably irrational
and thinking fast and slow thinking fast
and slow. Danny Conoman. Yes, exactly.
So I started reading all these books and
I became increasingly convinced of my
own,
um,
what I was fickleness and inability
to actually act rationally in life.
And once I became aware of that,
I think I became much softer
in my opinions and confidence
levels in life where
I, I want to question thoroughly
everything I do all the time.
And of course I miss all
layers a lot of time,
but I try to be present and knowing
that when I make a decision,
there's all kinds of layers behind it.
Many of us are probably flawed and
if I went back and evaluated it,
so I suppose it's just being present and
knowing it exists and how flawed we are
in our abilities when really we think
we're perfectly logical and consistent all
the time. We're just not. Yeah.
There's um, Dan Ariely's book is great,
predictably irrational.
Also a lot of really solid business
takeaways in terms of Hess show. Uh,
how people, I remember the
example he gave in a presentation,
I'm not sure if it's in the book,
I'm blanking of the checkout process that
the Economist magazine tested it all.
That's right. And it was like, you know,
get the print edition for
this amount by itself.
Get the digital edition is mount by
itself or get both for this amount and how
you're changing the pricing and
removing or adding options affected the,
the average order size. Yes.
So fascinating. Yes. Uh,
or adding in basically a not
a red herring. It's not that,
I don't think the right term,
but a a,
a straw man of an option that they
don't even really want you to choose,
but they'll add the cheaper option just
so they know you'll cause they know that
50% of the people will take
the middle option totally.
Just would have been the cheapest before,
but you would have then exact not chosen.
It just like restaurants,
I think put like the most expensive
pricey item in the top right corner to say
like, here's a $75 option. Everything
else is cheap at $32. Same thing with one.
Yeah. Very common. Uh,
when you are feeling,
and maybe maybe the answer
is you don't feel this way,
but when you're feeling say overwhelmed,
how do you unpack that and try to
reduce the sources of that? Overall,
I've gotten so much better over the years
now I just call a friend and just say,
you know what?
I'm feeling overwhelmed and I feel
terrible and I don't think I can do this.
And right just saying it out loud like,
yeah, I actually, I can, I got this,
but I just need to get that off my chest.
And I'm all, and so when I deal with,
when I work with entrepreneurs now,
people I'm invested in or
otherwise they say like,
if you want to chat anytime the
day and say anything, right,
no judgment on my side. Just say it out
loud, do it. And I think there's just,
it's, it's hard to do hard things. I
guess is has been Horowitz would say,
and having the ability to be vulnerable
and honest and transparent and raw with
other people is immensely helpful
for me. Yeah. But you weren't always,
no,
not always do that.
Now I was extremely private and
guarded and I owned everything.
I didn't dare come out of let go. And I
think men are particularly bad at that.
Uh, I agree. I, uh, yeah,
I've struggled with this myself and,
uh,
you're so on point and
it's such a simple answer,
seemingly self evident and
obvious. Right. But, uh,
I think it points to something
I've noticed about myself
and I tend to be stuck
in my kind of prefrontal
cortex. Yeah. Yeah. But if,
if you haven't kind of thought your way,
if you haven't rationalized your way or
that's not the right reasons your way
into a problem, it's hard to reason your
way out of it. I agree. Uh, just by,
by relying on the sort of internal
pro and con list and like schematic of
something that is purely emotional or
maybe based on some operating system flaw
that you're experiencing it. Yeah. Uh,
so yeah, just calling a friend. Yeah.
But that's like what I love about the
friendships that I have is I can go into a
conversation and I know when I leave,
two things will happen.
One is they will have challenged my
mental models that I can't change it.
I can't see my mental models and I
can't challenge myself very well,
but someone else can see it. So clearly
they can just call it out. Right.
And number two is when I leave
the competition is saying like,
I want to become a better person,
right? And I want to do more in life.
And I went to work harder.
Like those are the two things I think
I value the most and the attractions.
And so it's, I want to be
that for other people, right?
That when they bring something to
me, I can flip it and say, yeah,
here's a different model for
you to contemplate and to
hopefully when they leave
they say, you know what? Yes. Like,
I can do this and I've got that much more
energy to go about it. I find also, uh,
you know,
my version of talking to
someone very often is a
journaling in the morning. Yeah.
Just to take what I feel.
For instance,
if I'm feeling overwhelmed or having some
type of problem or source of anxiety,
putting it on paper makes me realize
how absurdly unfounded it is. I,
that's magical. And I think
that, you know, it can be,
if you don't have a friend to call,
who's going to challenge you in that way?
Just putting it freezing your thought on
paper can provide you with a sufficient
mirror in which you can see.
It's completely ridiculous.
Like I thought I had,
you know,
I looked like the elephant man and in
fact it's just the tiny little pimple on
the side of my head. Like, stop
freaking out. It's not a big deal.
And it's transient or reversible or both.
Um,
so a couple of 'em just to
shift gears for a minute.
A couple of a rapid fire
questions that you can you,
which don't have to have rapid
fire answers. Okay. You didn't,
so you can take an hour you want.
Uh,
but I'm not very witty quick. Okay. So
I'll try my best to get fast enough.
Uh,
in the last,
say six months to year or the
first thing that comes to mind,
what is something a purchase you've
made for less than a hundred dollars?
So it had a significantly
positive impact on your life.
Okay.
I have water. So take your time. Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
I would probably say,
I don't know. Okay. We'll come back
to it. All right. We'll come back. Uh,
do you idea, I mean that's, that's,
that's not the right question
because it gives you an out,
what historical figure
do you identify with?
So I love biographies.
I read probably a hundred plus biographies
and I don't know if there's one
person in particular might be
just a collection. Actually, no,
actually I would say
there's, there's a few, um,
one we talked about before
Shackleton, he resonates with me, uh,
at a deep level too.
I've read this book called a good
man by Mark Shriver about his dad,
sorry,
Trevor,
who worked in the Johnson administration
and started the Peace Corps and, and um,
he was a remarkable man and an
exceptional father, a good friend, loyal.
And he is a mental model of the kind
of person I want to be in life. So, um,
that three I'd probably say,
uh,
Viktor Frankl's man's search for
happiness. That happiness or meaning,
meaning. Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So
thanks very interrelated though. Yeah.
But the [inaudible] one of the driving
philosophies of life thing it drives me
the most is the stuff I guess I
find the most beautiful is the,
we have the ability to author life in
life. Don't worry about it, but we,
we can choose not to take
default fault routes.
We can choose to take different paths that
we can design and do whatever we want.
And I find that's why I
find entrepreneurship so
appealing is that you get to
design your own world.
And so in my office actually I hired,
I commissioned a graffiti artist. I, you
send me a photo of this, I remember. Yeah,
no, explain it please. Okay.
So on one side is get off the gray and
the other side is, is Harry Potter.
And they have their wands and staff's
pointed up and it's is exploding energy in
the middle of the air with his book
that's open blank pages for the pen.
And then above it, and graffiti is the
word dream. And the concept behind it is,
is Jrr Tolkien and,
and J K Rowling created worlds that
we inhabited through the tool of text,
right? They wrote this stuff
down and then we inhabited.
And so they literally authored worlds.
And we have that same ability as
entrepreneurs to build companies, right?
In everything we do,
we have that.
And especially our tools of creation now
that we're invested in at the Os Fund,
as I wanted to use pop culture figures
because I wanted my kids see this,
that they have that
ability to do that in life.
That they don't need to say
yes to the default options,
that they can carve her own path.
And even though it's incredibly hard,
it's gonna be painful to me,
it's so much more fulfilling than
a secure and safe way to live life.
And I think it is,
it's also just worth kind of rewinding
and pointing something out to folks,
which is, you didn't come
from, as far as I know,
I mean a wealthy family
where that was the kind of
a default.
I was that the default belief system,
maybe it was maybe a, despite the,
the financial challenges. Let me,
because I think I recall you
telling me that, uh, your,
your mom made some of your clothing that
you wear to school dead. Yeah. So it's,
it's not like you sort of came in with
every possible advantage that people
might assume is required
to think that way. Uh,
the authoring of your own world.
So
I'm going to come back to
that and I realized the,
the successful question I think
could be broken down a few ways.
So you just brought up with that
biography. The first one, a good man. The,
the thought in my head that you can model
different people for different traits.
Yeah. Right. Which has its own risks
because you might absorb bad habits.
That's why spending time with those
people without realizing it. Uh,
sort of like viruses in here, you
know, bugs in the [inaudible], but uh,
but that person correlated to the values,
right?
So modeling that person based on values.
If you were modeling who
is an entrepreneur or who
are entrepreneurs that you
admire for their aggression.
So I'd say actually like a
bunch of names pop up. Yeah.
People I've invested in at the less
fun. So a mean Craig venter. Yeah,
I hit longevity at Peter Diamandis.
Uh, there's, well Josh Tetrick,
Hampton Creek, Jason
Kelly, Gingko bioworks,
Daniel Fong at Lightsail,
Scott Phoenix at vicarious.
I mean we have a great roster of
incredibly passionate entrepreneurs.
Mustafa Suleyman deep mind.
I wasn't an investor there,
but I find him immensely
inspiring. But, um,
these entrepreneurs think
differently about the world and, um,
they're going after extremely
hard challenges and I'd
say there are Dacia send
determined and very aggressive.
Got It. Okay. So now let's see.
Do you define, would you describe
yourself as aggressive? I am. Uh,
in what ways are you most aggressive?
Um,
when I see something I want to go after,
be relentless. And, um,
which entrepreneurs do you
most admire for their end?
I'll have to say,
you'll have to choose either a smaller
subset of the people who invested with or,
uh, you can choose other people,
which might be safer, uh,
but for their resourcefulness.
All right,
so
let's come back to that.
I know I'm going to have a lot of
examples to think of people who,
who have faced near and a certain death
countless times was somehow they figured
out to maneuver right around the problems,
right?
To sort of a neo in the matrix,
do the backbend and dodge the bullets and
come back to that. Yeah, exactly. I mean,
that's the essence of entrepreneurship.
So that, that's actually a,
that's actually a good segue.
So what do you think an entrepreneur is?
What does an entrepreneur,
someone willing to us like? Um,
I think entrepreneurs and explorers have
a lot in common with like Shackleton
that they chart that he,
they head off an uncharted territory and
they maintain this ability to adapt to
circumstances that are chaotic,
unknown,
an extremely challenging and they can
maintain some order in all the chaos to
actually achieve a goal.
What are practices,
uh,
experiments maybe that people could
perform to help them develop those
characteristics?
Is there anything else that you find
sort of ports well over to that chaotic,
uncertain nature of startups,
small companies.
So I guess we,
I have a lot of conversations with
people who want to start their own thing.
And one of my favorite
questions to ask is,
is this an itch or is it, you know,
burning, right? So it's just an itch.
It's not sufficient and it gets to this
point of how badly do you really want
it? And for me, I burned the boats.
Like there was no way I was going to
get a job and so fell you with never an
option. I had to make this work
and I did have jobs on the way,
but that was just to simply
to pay the bills. But, um,
failure just wasn't a
solution I would accept.
And so I think I want to get it
entrepreneurs that how badly you want it,
what will you do to get there?
Yeah,
I find it very difficult in the current
environment to identify those people
because things are so frothy right now.
A lot of people who would otherwise
be risk intolerant and fearful of
uncertainty are jumping into the fray as
founders. I mean you have in this look,
I, lot of my very close friends come
out of Mckinsey and places like that,
but when people with very
high paid consultants,
consulting jobs are then jumping into
startups, I started to wonder what, uh,
what is on the, what is on the
horizon? And if I look back,
a very kind of macro timing way to
at least narrow down the field a bit.
So it's easier to find. Those people
seem to be investing during recessions.
So that sort of investing right after
crashes it left sort of the people who
couldn't conceive of doing anything else.
Standing on the playing field. Yeah.
And the sort of fairweather investors,
the fairweather entrepreneurs all went
back to doing whatever they perceive to
be charted territory. Yeah, exactly.
Me, I guess I want to be careful,
like I don't want to be like an
entrepreneur definition snob and right.
And suggest that I was going to come
out and pound the table and yell at you
about that.
But these attributes are held by people
within companies who are starting their
companies who are working with larger
institutions. Right. But it's, it's, uh,
it just inherently people who can create,
do and see what others
cannot or will not do. Right.
That they will blaze something to
others will follow or benefit from. And,
hmm. Uh, let me,
let me dive in to a couple
of other questions also. Uh,
do you have a, uh, a book
that you've gifted often?
Are there any books that you've
gifted to other people? Often?
I have gifted a good man to quite a
few people and Shackleton and Victor
Frankel's book. Um, they're good man.
I gift because if we contemplate how,
like I wonder what would my
son or daughter say about me?
Why kind of biography would they? Right.
And that's a model for me. I would want,
um, Shackleton. That's how I want
to behave in life. And Frankl, uh,
that's how he,
he,
his basic point is no matter the
conditions we surround ourselves in,
we can author our life, right? We
can offer whatever, how we respond.
And then I guess it also love
throwing their set. Artha yeah.
Have you had that Herman Hesse,
women Hesta I guess in German.
I love that book that came up
yesterday on a, on a walk with
someone. I won't name because it was
a private conversation, but very,
very successful guy that I also
admire a lot for his sort of deep,
deep thinking or unimportant philosophical
questions sit harder came up. Um,
that's also come up I think with my
conversation with Josh Waitzkin who is on
the second interview ever on this podcast,
who is the basis for searching for
Bobby Fischer known as a chess prodigy.
But yeah,
really,
I don't think it's appropriate cause he's
applied is going to learning framework
to many different areas. But that
book comes up a lot. It's a very, uh,
sort of allegorical. But, um,
oftentimes I think that deep truths can
be explored more effectively in fiction
and nonfiction. Right. Uh,
because it pulls you out of your normal
context. Yes. In a way. Yes. You're,
you're not, you're your programs. You're
problem solving software isn't running.
So that blindsides you new
mental models. Yeah, exactly. Uh,
the,
um,
I had a profound that just escaped
my semi ketogenic brain or Qatar,
Bahrain.
I'm probably right on the,
I think we were talking about this just
before and I had 0.6 millimeters cause I
fell out of Ketosis and then I'm just
getting back and had some coconut oil.
But I think that's kept me going for
about 60 minutes. So I'm probably in the,
in the, the no man's land, the gray
zone of substrate suffering. Uh,
what's, uh, if you could have,
if you had a huge billboard you
could place anywhere and uh,
you can put whatever text you want on it,
where would you put it
and what would it say?
Yeah.
Uh, let's see. I would put it
in New York and it would say,
okay,
do an anonymous and random
act of kindness today.
Why New York?
Okay.
For if, if you're giving me the constraint
of a single billboard, that's right.
And I want the broadest exposure I'll
get to New York where the density is
highest. Got It. Uh, I like it.
Good answer. Um, if
you were giving advice to your
30 year old self,
what advice would you give
that?
Um,
no matter what comes your way,
no matter how hard things Phil,
that I had the power to overcome
and be at peace with it.
Good advice. I think that's a great
place to, uh, to start wrapping up.
Is there, um, anything else you'd like to
share with the audience? Resourcefulness,
examples,
anything else?
Yeah. You know, one thing. Um,
so I do a lot of projects
with my kids and like,
for example,
we started a few businesses together
and we wrote a children's book together.
And as I think about the coming
generation of makers and doers,
that they're the people who will
define our world so dramatically.
If I think about who they aspire to be
like and what kind of things they want to
do and how we write the operating
systems of their app or aspirations and,
and endeavors, I think that, um,
I'm encouraged by watching
my own kids grow up,
that I see a bright future that we can
trust these incredibly powerful tools of
creation can be used for, for good things.
They go to subjective of course, but,
um,
but that we can actually change a
humanity in fundamental ways and that the
rising generation, if we do
it right, we'll have amazing
ability to contribute to,
uh, to our wellbeing.
And if, if there are,
and I'm sure there are new parents
listening to this, uh, and in fact,
I have someone I know very closely
who's about to have his first kid. Yeah.
Um,
what are a few activities or experiments
or collaborations that you would
encourage them to have
with their kids or habits?
It could be anything but just general
try these two things. Three things,
whatever it might be with your kids.
It's like my personal philosophy is I
try to be relevant in my kids' lives as
self example. My, in my, my sixth grader,
he's in a public school and they don't
have any technology in the school.
And so I've been working with a principal
to bring technology in the school.
And the way we're doing it is we're
running a test in his class where they are
using the scientific method to say if
we bring technology in the classroom,
will it improve educational experience?
And so they have to test it out and use
pros and cons and go thought process.
And then each of the, then there's
six groups making a documentary.
And so I'm with the teacher working
with six groups of students. Yeah.
Six groups of students within the class
and they each are making like a three to
four minute documentary
on the process of testing.
The scientific method of does
is technology in the classroom.
I posit for nave experience
or what are the pros and cons.
And so I'm working with his teacher to
do that and doing the filmmaking and
plotting out the storyboarding
and identifying what the
scientific method looks
like. And that gives me all
these opportunities to talk
about everything that's
relevant in his life,
in ways that are meaningful.
And so when we have conversations, I'm not
just saying, hey, how's your day? Fine.
And that's the end of compensation,
right? But it's relevant. So, uh,
the same is true with
my fourth grader and my,
and my daughter who's in preschool.
But I would say parents,
they get engaged in the children's
lives to be truly relevant,
to understand the underlying context
of who they like, who they dislike,
who are the friends, who are
the people who are, you know,
saying mean things to them.
What are they worried about in school?
So that's been a helpful my,
they ship with my kids and I think it's
really helped us form a very strong bond.
Are there any
traditions that you've built into
the family that are nonobvious?
Christmas is very common for a lot
of people of course, but are there,
are there any other
traditions or rituals that uh,
you've developed with your kids?
Yeah, so when we sit down for dinner,
I always have a question for
them. Like, uh, last week, uh,
on Saturday night we had this discussion
of what does it mean to be good?
And they're jamming like,
you know, it's like, uh, 11,
nine and five and they're jamming on this
question of what it means to be good.
And I raised all kinds of questions like,
what you think is good is not
necessarily what I think is good.
We have these different interpretations
and is there a single definition of good?
And so Mike by five-year-old's
raising her hand, offering up her in,
but which is amazing,
but they walk away,
they're surprisingly bright and
had an amazingly good insights.
So I tried to have these conversations
with them and sometimes it lasts like 10
minutes before chaos breaks
out in the house, you know.
But at least we have this moment
where we can connect on really serious
questions and they can
explore these philosophically,
which I have found to be beneficial
in both their development but also our
relationship.
What in your mind are common mistakes
that parents make aside from doing the
opposite of the two things you
just described? So we were,
this is up for opinion of
course, but we were at a, uh,
my five year old had this little party
for her preschool and I took her over and
we were at the park and there was this
merry go round and there was like 20 kids
on the merry go round.
It's like there was some older kids going
really fast around and like sometimes
a kid would fall, like fall in the
dirt and get trampled by their friends.
Just friends or for exactly.
So,
but there was like two camps of parents
and broke out. One camp was like,
no way is my child going to be involved
in this terribly dangerous endeavor,
which is a reasonable thing to say,
right? Because it's pretty dangerous.
And they could, someone
could, could really hurt.
And there are other parents more like
myself, like, look, they figure it out.
Like if they get hurt,
I'm sure that the recover and it'd be a
great experience for them to learn about,
about big objects moving
very fast and right.
These principles of physics
and the flesh. So, I mean,
my daughter got on and she was in
the mix of all this stuff, but um,
I'm certainly of the philosophy that I
like kids to go explore and do on their
own. And if they make mistakes, that's
fine. They can learn. But if we,
if there's too much inherent protection
structured that they just forego those
learning experiences that will,
they're taught that they're fragile
and I think therefore they develop the
belief that they're fragile. Yeah.
I mean now granted I think back to,
I mean I'm sure you probably
have this like juke gasoline,
gallon of gasoline and the street example.
I think back to some of the stuff I did
where I'm just like I cannot believe I
was allowed to do that. Exactly. Yeah.
Skateboarding off of ramps
in the middle of the street,
wear like flip over and smashed my head
on the asphalt and Cognac hus myself.
Exactly. She's like, oh my God. But yeah,
all of those things taught
me ultimately like the,
either this too shall pass or like okay,
like you earned your lumps
now you know not to do that.
But you also know like you,
you were able to weather the storm
and get through it. Exactly. Yeah.
So we got an a four
wheeler, uh, two weeks ago,
my 11 and nine year olds and I said,
okay, I'm going to put your helmets on.
I'm going to give you a two
minute lesson on how to go,
how to go forward and how to go backwards,
how to break.
I'm to give you some lessons,
like don't go into a ditch,
don't go on a hillside though.
You'll turn over.
But I'm an expecting you to now go out
for five minutes and come back safely and
tell me how you did it.
Like what were your thought processes?
How'd you stay safe for the risk you took?
But I want them to do it and
I'm not going with you. Right?
So you go and come back and
they came back in one piece.
But it was a good experience for
them to tell me like, look, Hey dad,
this is how we looked at the risk.
This is how we thought that we'd
potentially going to get into a problem.
They ran into a tree going
slowly, but right. What they
talked about it, which was,
I thought it was really
helpful. Well, you know, and uh,
yeah,
I just think it's,
I think you're a fascinating guy.
I think you're very inspiring guy.
And as I think forward to at
someday having kids myself, I,
I love asking you these
types of questions and uh,
this has been a blast. So number one,
thank you very much for taking the time.
I always love having these conversations.
This is our first one on
the record and a second,
where can people learn more about you,
about the [inaudible] fund and so on.
Ios fund.co cl is where
all of our investments are.
And um,
I'm active on Twitter,
so happy to have ongoing discussions
about the various things we talked about.
But what's your Twitter handle? Uh, Brian
Underscore Johnson with a y. Got it.
At Brian and Square Johnson. I'll put
that in the show notes as well. Uh, any,
any parting thoughts or comments? Now,
Tim, I just love this. I mean, we've,
we've had fantastic conversations,
you know, uh, over time.
So this is fun to actually do this.
I'm formally and, uh, you know,
I've really enjoyed the friendship.
Likewise man. And this is a,
it's I'm so glad that I was able to,
uh,
to try to give people a view into
these conversations that we have a,
it's so much fun for me and I always
come away with a bunch of things that I
want to try or a bunch of
assumptions I want to test.
And I think you really good at not only
helping to prepare people for what could
be a very glorious future of
sort of infinite creation,
but also giving them the belief in the
first place that is possible. And so, uh,
I really believe that
you're a force for good.
So thank you for spreading
mmm.
Confidence, uh, in, in the
world. And I think you're,
you're trying to really
leave set and sort of a,
a dent in the universe and an impact.
So thank you my friend.
Appreciate that a lot. I
appreciate it. So to be continued,
everybody hope you enjoyed this.
This was a blast for me. Uh,
we're going to continue to hang out,
but off the record and if
you'd like to chat with Brian,
ping him on Twitter and let
us know what you think. Uh,
certainly if there's anything
that's struck you, please, uh,
let me know what was most memorable in
the comments on the blog for our blog.com
all spelled out.
You can find the show notes
for this episode and every
other episode by going to
four hour workweek all spelled out,
four hour work week.com forward
slash podcast and until next time,
thank you for listening.
This episode is brought to you by 99
designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups
that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one
New York Times Number One,
Wall Street Journal and the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with
designers from around the world.
And here's how it works. Whether you need
a t shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be.
You submit that project and from around
the world we'll send you sketches and
mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you
who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that
I'll be sharing it in the future.
But in the meantime, if you want
to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by
Athletic Greens. I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day, and you can get 50 oh my
gosh, 50% off. Yes, 50% off.
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim, check it out.
It's tasty, but more important.
It will help you not screw up when
you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me, it just covers the
basis, takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my buddy and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward
slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.